put a vibrator on the Rumba welcome to
west world welcome to spoiler party
where we talk about movies TV and other
stuff today we are watching West world
the season 1 finale who has seen it ok
together yeah we did I have never seen
an episode of the show at all do you
know what it's about it's about like a
adult ish theme park where it's like
western 18 late 1900s where people can
go and live out like their cowboy
fantasies when you say doltish I
automatically think something sexual
yeah yeah I look like that you go and
you have sex with these robots
are these the kind of robots where if
you like rip off their fake skin it's
just like metal and so this is white
silicon thing oh so they're like 3d
printed they're like they're yeah it's
like it's weird it's like they're dipped
in milk yeah we talked about the milk
baths but before that they were more
like robotic like she is now okay so
she's like a 3GS and now they're at like
an X yeah okay yet again another
unrealistic female body sandwich it's
not even all skin and bones bones are
there black robots or is it like very
historically accurate the owner of the
brothel is black I'd be friends with her
because that's where I'd want to work
she's very cool you weren't already in
the brothel she's one of the coolest no
no I got brothel confused with the
saloon okay singing number drinking
everybody under the table one two three
four yeah I'm gonna be for Halloween
it's your saloon a saloon home working
at the good ole brothel just working at
the brothel try to make it out of this
living that's not an honest listen yep
an honest living
big big this place feels more real than
the real world except it isn't because
you can't really fight back
do they like screen people before you
they're like you can go into this world
no it's just it's all just money yeah
you got cash welcome to West world
laying on top of the hill with a friend
look it over at a bunch of people that
would what be what I did Brokeback
Mountain yeah actually I broke back mail
in the [ __ ] out of West world okay what
are some pickup lines that the
characters would use to like pick
someone up in a bar you like milk I
would look at West world as
really nice practice for me and I would
go there and I would try to hit on
robots and just you know see what wines
work but they're not like a good gauge
of like whether and I would work right I
don't they seem human-like I get one it
is consensual sex no I think not all the
time you like do bad things it's like
the same question is like is it
consensual sex if you have sex with a
vibrator
right vibrator doesn't talk back to me
late it doesn't but you can get a five
but they both neither one have you
talking vibrators I don't even know
there's gotta be vibrators that'll like
read you a book or something speaker and
I thank the depth audible like yeah
audible.com yeah so what would your
pickup line be well I don't know yet I
would need the drive to think about
think about James Marsden hey James
Barr's just shot every other robot in
the park is just you and him now pick
them up you know what you know what so
you're standing there's dead bodies all
around you covered in blood oil God
James you've been through a lot today
huh
you seem tense let's go work out some of
that tension on a bed with you I don't
know if you need to specify like that
visit I think I'm on the bed you were
there
don't say with you want to have me just
work out some tension I think that's a
better start than with with you on top I
don't know there's plenty of dip
[Music]
is that him yeah yeah only find myself
oh my god
Wow oh that's awesome look at you guys
so if you had to describe something at
Westworld in a tweet are your experience
at West well on tweet it would be oh
it's like the bad permit meme where it's
like good Kermit is like go have fun at
the amusement park and then it's bad
Kermit like pub sex and murder everyone
and like try to take over the world this
is basically real-life Grand Theft Auto
[Music]
what the hell is this show that's fun
yeah
[ __ ] I have so many questions I'm
curious about season two I saw something
people are talking about if Ford is
really dead or not Anthony Hopkins yeah
right if that was a host yeah because
you can just make a fake you and then he
was murdered to caused the chaos but
Ford is really somewhere oh yeah I like
that just saying I got the very first
scene of season two takes place in a
different world
if not Shogun world in some other world
then it's going to be like the effect of
what wess world had on this new world is
how one districts rebellion causes like
other rebellion yeah I wonder if they're
gonna find out that all of them have
always been robots
except for William and then at the very
end we find out that William wasn't a
Truman Show type thing once he figures
that out that he's been played the whole
time he killed himself
Wow mmm I could even follow yes give it
a dummy all of the robots think that
they're special and they think that
they're finding a way out of it but
really they're programmed and everyone's
programmed even the people that you
think are other humans
so William thinks that everyone else is
like other humans like he's one of the
other humans but really everyone's a
robot and everyone from all of the waits
for him to discover and he did next
occupy gage yeah and then at the end he
finds out that it was only him playing
the whole thing
and then he kills themselves you know I
need the whole company no no I think he
better take this yeah wild no no I'm
with you he could have invented this
like 40 years ago and then he's just in
too deep and he forgot and so now he's
like yeah he's been playing it for that
long yeah exactly so that's why he
thinks it's real life and yet he still
has like this fake narrative but it's
actually I'm with you so if we were to
recast anyone in West world who would we
peg
Oprah if she were to be cast as like
Anthony Hopkins like their opposite
people right
like Oprah could never be like nefarious
and like connive that's scarier when
someone tells you something really up
with like a smile then it's more
horrifying
we need Oprah villain yeah and Harris's
character would be funnier if it was
played by Tiffany Haddish I also think
every character be funny very playboy
Tiffany eyes or Kate McKinnon are we
going for a comedy character be funnier
for Tiffany would you rather be a black
hat or be a white hat well that is
deceiving because he's in a white hat
William and he's a bad guy Logan from
the black I think everybody eventually
becomes a black hat I think everybody
wears both hats I think I would just
enjoy my life more in West world as a
white hat person now big dick Daisy pits
black would you rather be a host and not
know it
or know that you are a host do you host
and not know it yeah yeah absolutely all
I'm saying when I playing the sins and I
put on free will they get very confused
when you all of a sudden force them to
do something else it's better if you
just take freewill off the table would
you rather stay entirely in sweetwater
stay entirely in pariah Sweetwater's
like the star town pariah I don't
remember
Mariah
give me some Sodom and Gomorrah Logan is
your tour guide or go it alone
god what a Logan as my target Oh I mean
hello good as my port but I don't want
Logan to introduce me to the robots I'm
gonna I want to find them on my own call
me a hopeless romantic but I would like
to find my robots robot in spend one
night logical storage we could choose a
host to keep you company or would you
rather spend a night locked in jail with
no one to keep you company yeah we know
storage Oh cold storage one night is not
terrible you're all naked with their
dictator yeah you know having sex you
sweat you'll get you're not gonna have
sex but you could choose a host to keep
you company what do I mean now you can
also talk to the host I don't know I
will meditate in the jail I'm fine I'll
be war I've been a long time you know
what we should do what let's go to my
apartment we'll turn on my Roomba we'll
watch it run into walls and you can also
practice your pickup lines on my Roomba
let's do it put a vibrator on the Roomba
welcome to West world and then I'll be
just the guy who fixes the room but when
you've destroyed it with your sex thanks
for watching spoiler party comment below
your thoughts let us know what you think
about Westworld and your prediction but
let us say how I'm right and everyone
else is wrong about what's gonna happen
on the next sheet don't do it there's no
way anything you said is going to be
still in this video I talk
[Laughter]
[Music]